hey how's it going bro what is life
beyond death probably the toughest
question that we all want answered well
you're in luck mister today we're gonna
find that out we're gonna predict what
happens when you pass through the circle
of life
let's do it everyone knows I am a level
two psychic skilled but I ask you boys
for help for creativity Oh Mila Kunis is
going with Mila Kunis shaving cream
alright I'm picking up multiple great
suggestions and then Beach
the [ __ ] am i doing
this is where I am this is my life now
Jesus Christ saddest thing I've ever
seen
there we go Mila Kunis shaving cream
Beach that is what you might see when
you die next one we have link we have
fabulous okay there we go Tesco link
Tesco fabulous let's begin
I don't know why I said like that row
let's bro it out I had to touch go bro
meet me at a Tesco do you want to have
some touch girl
how do we make such a fabulous man
already more families I know dude you
could do it you could do it you could do
it dude turn then Nintendo's gonna hate
me even more now Jesus Christ how do you
wear a pair of balls I slushes as these
link zelda a link between two balls how
can we make a man so fabulous more
fabulous that is the question that I ask
myself every day when I look into the
mirror ooh oh yes I've made the right
decisions in life after all like how one
of his boobs is bigger than the other
that's completely normal link like don't
stress about it why am I putting so much
[ __ ] effort into this of course we
can't forget about the kawaii effect and
baby Haiti I would date this me link in
a heartbeat this is probably the new
upcoming Zelda game tesco DLC links
part-time job and one is hat I'm jealous
and we got Harry Styles onions gay club
if we get that right we have a bunch of
handsome men in the background how about
that onions
how the [ __ ] who asks for onions nice
car out there it is onions [ __ ]
onions what so fair fair fabulous lag
cribs I love how they feel when when you
peel them when you chop them and
and your eyes cry I love that people
hate that I love that good onion mmm
good times good onion as I like say said
it many times in my videos is the onion
King of course Harry Styles is the onion
King
all hail the onion master this looks
like the latest Lady Gaga outfit or some
shape and there you have it Harry Styles
onion gay bar I think this is my
favorite because if you look closely you
just really want to touch it it's kind
of like touching a man's abs you just
really want to touch it I mean this
makes me cry yeah that makes sense
because it's onions you ruined
I feel like this picture has a weird
backstory it's really like deep he makes
you think like old good art okay let's
do another one
all right we got Kim K dolphin space I
got this no problem who doesn't want to
be a dolphin come on don't don't don't
mess with me here dolphin I don't know
the next single by Kanye West
I'm Kim Kayne I approve of this dolphin
I'm a [ __ ] dolphin [ __ ]
sorry
[ __ ] genius there you have it I think
this is one is my favorite it's Kim
Kardashian
space and dolphin why doesn't she have
any hands this hands have dolphins I
mean there's dolphin half hands that's
right
stupid question I'm getting this
tattooed on my butt good and you want to
see any of these when you die if not
maybe I'll make some more for you as
always this is basically a game about
building furniture that you get from a
care I reach people can't build
furniture everyone knows this everyone
so I'm just gonna go ahead and start
here we have a Buick Burke which doesn't
mean [ __ ]